ten thousand acres in the heart of
Seneca County were taken over by the
federal government for the construction
of a great Ordnance Depot
word went out that contractors needed
eight or nine thousand workmen
Seneca is not a populist County outside
of the Villages of Waterloo which is the
county seat and Seneca Falls the latest
population figures give the rest of the
county about fourteen thousand persons
so Seekers for work came from various
parts of New York and from other states
the center of attraction was the
employment office which was set up in
the former Grange Hall at the little
village of kendaya
the normal population of Candia was 15
persons there was a star and a church
a school The Grange hall and three or
four houses
upon this village with 15 inhabitants
descended some 300 men women and
children who sought temporary homes near
the employment office
and hundreds came seeking employment who
didn't know where they would live
at once health problems arose too big
for local Health officials are
Complicated by the absence of local
Health boards so the State Health
Department came to help here is the
district sanitary engineer looking over
the handiest well in the village it is
obviously bad so the pump is discarded
the well inspected and thoroughly
chlorinated for protection if the water
should be used
foreign
it is covered and posted with a warning
sign
the next day the district State Health
officer and engineer find the part of a
deserted House's fast disappearing to
make firewood for cooking breakfasts
the cover has been removed from the well
and various means have been devised to
get the water up from the well
this in spite of the close proximity of
a filthy privy
however a test shows that in spite of
themselves these migrant workers have
been protected even if they drink the
water they will not be made ill however
unpleasant it may taste
not a single well was found safe
originally but after improvements to the
well in front of the schoolhouse it
yielded safe though sometimes scant
water
behind the employment office was a
single dilapidated insanitary privy used
by men and women alike within easy
swarming distance flies found the only
restaurant so-called a straw carpeted
tent with an old two-burner oil stove
of course the privy was closed and
generously treated with Clara de blime
a new privy was set up exclusively for
women with a lock key available to women
only and new flight proof screened
privies for men were constructed
in the old schoolhouse was set up an
immunization and child health clinic in
and from which worked the state nurses
and doctors
the nurse visits a family living in an
old school bus
children are brought to the clinic for
vaccination and immunization
another nurse shows a mother how to
protect whatever water she may have been
able to get
but good water must be made available so
the state trucks safe water into the war
project area
the truck was originally used to
transport health education material but
now it carries containers of safe water
which are set up at convenient locations
all over the entire area health problems
are to be met
here is a squatters camp on nearby
seated all of the sanitary problems
except that of water cold water for
bathing
an enterprising individual in the nearby
Village of Ovid has rented the old
schoolhouse and offers rooms for rent
they are small but clean
they have new comfortable beds
some of the beds are arranged in
dormitories
boarding houses spring up everywhere
this one at the corners at candea
accommodates from 12 to 26 persons at a
time
but the problem of Sanitation is just
the same here as it is in a tent or
trailer colony
and the old Wells must be protected
the folks must have safe water
yes War Industry activities make local
health problems which must be met
promptly
the district State Health officer seemed
to be The Logical one to organize the
solution of these problems he and his
office went into high to find the
answers no need to go into all the
details of the negotiations suffice that
by Fall plans have been developed
approved and put into operation whereby
the Seneca County Fairgrounds at
Waterloo became the site of a modern
trailer camp
trailers furnished by the farm security
administration were gathered from
various parts of the country and set up
on the Waterloo Fairgrounds supplemented
by private trailers at Trailer City soon
took farm and fortunately for the
workers and their families was ready for
occupancy well before the first snow
fell
with the trailer City organized now fell
upon the District Health office the task
of handing the countless details
connected with the mass movement of
occupants evacuation notices had to be
made out and served and the whole
administrative Machinery set up for the
miniature City
on a cheerless cold rainy day the
Waterloo trailer city was formally
dedicated with appropriate speeches by
representatives of the farm Security
Administration
the United States Army the State
Department of Health and the local civil
Administration
residents of the community took an
active interest for example the American
Legion had a prominent part in the
dedication the chilled winds Forerunner
of the wintry days so close at hand
could not fail to make every worker
present thankful for being able to leave
the inadequate protection of billowing
canvas for the Cozy shelter of well-made
trailers arranged in orderly lighted
streets and avenues comfortable inside
cozy by day adequate by night
warm with real cooking facilities
good refrigeration and plenty of
cupboard space
sanitary requirements were supplied in
central buildings laundry tubs sinks
toilets with modern running water
even shower baths
with good hot water a far cry from what
these folks found when they descended by
thousands on the tiny unprepared
communities
and outside the trailer City nothing was
neglected to provide adequate Health
protection inspection of Wells continued
everywhere workers gathered to live
modest private Capital set up new
sanitary restaurants which were the
object of constant inspection and
supervision
Health lessons were quickly learned and
restaurant Proprietors cooperated by
installing some of the most efficient
modern equipment
even the youngsters kept the spirit and
Junior Police did really efficient work
trailers did more than simply shelter
workers and their families here's one
that served as a splendid child health
clinic
well youngsters were kept well by
frequent physical examinations
and protected by vaccination
buildings too in other parts of the
territory were utilized for inoculation
in general clinics everywhere the
state's Public Health nurses helped in
protecting the health welfare and
happiness of these workers and their
families as a symbol of how one
Community handled the health problems
brought to it by A Great War activity
glanced back at this discarded School
Bus
shared on successive Nights by three
families who slept in their automobiles
on the other nights
and then plants at the community day
Nursery conducted in the trailer City at
Waterloo
each day one mother would care for the
youngsters of the others while their
mothers went about their necessary work
yes War Industry activities do create
real health problems but they can be and
are being met